-Our guest tonight is an Academy
Award and Emmy-nominated
actor and musician you know --
you know and love
from movies like
"Thor: Ragnarok,"
"Independence Day"
and Jurassic Park.
His new album with
The Mildred Snitzer Orchestra,
"Play Well With Others,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show,
the one, the only
our friend, Jeff Goldblum,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Thank you, my friend.
-It's very exciting that we get
to hear a little music from you.
I want to ask you.
Are you the sort of musician
that spends a lot
of time looking
at things
like album art?
-I thought you were gonna say --
I thought that was period.
"You're sort of a musician."
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought that sentence
was gonna end there.
-I would never.
I know you're very accomplished.
-I'm sort of a musician,
you're correct.
You'd be correct.
What were you going to say?
I'm sorry.
-Well, I was...
[ Laughter ]
You know, I feel like
picking the album art,
I know this isn't
your first one,
but do you spend
a lot of time looking at it
or are you sort of let it go?
Are you our hands off
or hands on?
-A little of both.
I have terrific help.
Andrew Vottero,
who also cooks up
sometimes what I wear --
-Oh, wow.
-Mostly all the time --
is a genius, and he reached out
to a friend of mine,
Kyle Ng.
-Okay.
-Who's spectacular,
who is the --
who created Brain Dead.
Brain Dead is the company
that did that that thing.
-Yeah, some people now.
-If you know them,
they make fantastic clothing.
We're not in L.A.,
but in L.A.,
you know the silent
movie theater on Fairfax?
-Uh-huh.
-They took it over.
He now curates a beautiful
collection of movies there,
and has a clothing
store upstairs.
Anyway, he's done
this kind of thing before.
We asked him to
and his team to do this.
He came up with that.
We had some hands on
collaborative involvement in it,
and that's the story.
And he made a -- he made
some merch for us, too.
-Some merchandise.
-Yes, or merch.
-Yeah.
-As we...
[ Laughter ]
You know, we say merch.
Yes, merchandise.
-I just feel like
I want to, you know,
like, not everybody's, you know,
cool cat,
goes to a lot of concerts.
I want to let them know
what you're talking about.
-I apologize.
It was my fault entirely.
-Yes.
-Yes, yes.
-Okay, got --
I mean, let's make this show
for everybody,
the people
who know what merch means
and the people might want
a little help.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-Thank you.
-Now, I have to ask you.
-Hey, to that,
I say to you, teach me.
Let me learn from you.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, well...
-That's a -- that's a line
from a movie.
What movie is it from?
-Teach me,
let me learn from you.
-Teach me.
Let me learn from you.
-"Lolita."
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But that was an impulsive
and --
-Yup, impulsive, yeah.
-I don't wanna --
-I love "Lolita."
You like the -- you like that
Nabokov book, of course.
-Yes.
-And the first "Lolita"
or the second,
which do you like?
The remake with --
-I feel like we're in
dangerous ground
when you're like, I love.
-No, no, no. We can disagree.
-The Kubrick --
the Kubrick "Lolita"
is a fantastic film.
-The which one?
-The Kubrick.
-Oh, the Kubrick.
I love that movie.
-Yeah.
-Yes, with Shelley Winters,
of course.
-Yes, of course.
James Mason.
In any case, where we --
I dropped mental breadcrumbs.
What we were talking
about is...
-The quote from the movie.
What movie?
-What movie?
-Teach me.
Let me learn from you.
-Wait, Fred,
do you have any guesses?
-I don't.
-You don't know, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm going to give you a clue.
It was spoken
by Robert De Niro.
-Oh, "Teach me,
let me learn from you"
by Robert De Niro.
-Teach me.
Let me learn from you.
-What.
-I could tell you
to whom he said it in the movie.
I could tell you
who directed the movie.
-Okay, but just know this is
we're no longer talking
about you at this point.
I want...
Okay, I do appreciate as a guest
that you fully don't care
that you've
just started playing...
-I don't care.
-...movie trivia
with the audience.
-I'm off very little interest to
myself really, as it turns out.
-"Teach me.
Let me learn from you."
-Yeah.
-Animated?
[ Laughter ]
-Name one animated movie
that Robert De Niro has done.
Oh, you know what?
He was in that Bullwinkle movie,
but he was not,
it was live action, so...
-The shark one.
-Yes.
-Oh, yeah. The shark movie.
There's Wally over there
jumping in.
-Oh, really?
Thank you, Wally.
I'm not familiar with that.
No.
So I could -- or I could tell
you who --
I'm choking -- or --
Oh, what's happening?
-You don't have to have a
lozenge in your mouth.
-Somebody said I was obliged
to do that.
Who?
-Oh, right.
That is a new thing
we're doing with our guests.
-Yeah. [ Clears throat ]
-Seth -- Seth likes...
[ Laughs ]
-They said
Seth likes everyone to be...
-Did it look like somebody
who worked on this show
that said put a lozenge
in right now?
[ Laughter ]
-Here's a good game.
Next time I stick my tongue out,
will I have something
on it or not?
-Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good. That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was --
That's from "Lolita," that game.
-No, it's not,
but you have to play.
Yes or no?
-Okay. Yes or no? Yes.
[ Laughter ]
That game stinks.
Alright.
Who did Robert De Niro
say that line to.
-His character's name,
this will give it away,
is Rupert Pupkin.
-Oh, okay. So there you go,
"King of Comedy."
-Yeah, that was very good.
-There you go.
And he said it to
to Sandra Bernhard.
-Well, there you go.
-"Teach me.
-Let me learn from you."
-Okay, well --
well, here we are.
And we're obviously running out
of time, but, no.
[ Laughter ]
We do --
Luckily, we have you here.
I get to talk to you
for a little bit longer
after the commercial break,
but I want to ask a question.
-I had another couple of ideas,
by the way.
I want to hear your question.
[ Clears throat ]
-Don't talk. Give yourself a
moment to finish the lozenge.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me spit it out.
I had two ideas.
Your hair reminds me
of Clint Eastwood
in what movie?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, "Play Misty for Me."
-No.
-Okay.
-That could be.
-It's younger.
"Dirty Harry."
-No.
-Okay. What?
-That could be.
"Paint Your Wagon.
"Paint Your Wagon," alright.
-Lee Marvin, with Lee Marvin.
-Yeah.
-Also, you're -- you're a
a big fan of P.G. Wodehouse.
-I love P.G. Wodehouse
-I do, too.
I've read all of his book.
Now, can I'll tell you
something?
-Yeah.
-I feel like it's "Wode" house
and I've been saying
it wrong my whole life.
-You know, I said...
[ Laughter ]
I was in a Broadway
show once.
I had a line,
something about P.G.
This is before
I was familiar with him.
I pronounced it "Wode" house,
a critic said,
"And Mr. Goldblum,
maybe he was trying
to mispronounce it,
said 'Wode' house.
It's obviously 'Wood' house."
I believe it's "Wood" house.
-Yeah.
-Since then, I've read
most of his things.
I love that.
-The best.
We recommended for you.
-Okay, great.
-So...
-And that -- okay.
-And your question,
now your question.
Oh! No, that's all.
[ Laughter ]
No, and now your question.
I'm so sorry.
-My question is this.
-Then I had one other idea.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you want to -- do you want
to throw it out now?
-Yeah.
-Okay, but just so you know,
when you're --
after your idea,
we're going to go to commercial,
then we're going to come back.
And you have to let me ask you
at least two things.
-I will.
-Okay.
-What color?
This is a great game.
This is also a great game.
You know, when you get paint
chips or fingernail polish color
and you say to your participant,
your fellow gamers,
you say, here are the names
of all the colors.
Here's what they look like.
-Okay.
-I'm going to tell you
all the -- all the names,
but I'm going to make up one.
You guess which one
I've made up.
-Oh, so like a Sherwin,
more like paint strip?
You make one up?
-Yeah.
And they have such whimsical
names that, you know, yeah.
What name of color
would your shirt be?
-What name of my color?
Well, I would say like
prune would be right.
-Oh, prune Danish or, yeah,
yes is good.
-Okay. Yeah, what else
would you think?
-Aubergine.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-That's all. What's your
question? What's your question?
-Well, my question is we're
going to go to commercial.
-Okay.
-Are my question,
I guess, is,
are you okay with that?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
-We'll be right back
with more from Joe Goldblum.